when the list item is clicked use
androids toast mechanism to display the
weather forecast string a toast is a
pop-up that displays a message for a few
seconds before fading out it's
particularly useful for debugging where
it can be use as a way to indicate
status visually without altering the app
UI we're gonna put our ListView set item
click listener into forecastfragment
inside of the oncreateview method we'll
just start typing list view dot set on
item click listener and let the
autocomplete fill in the rest inside of
this function we're going to add click
listener which we can instantiate in
place so here's where we can call the
code in Android to display the toast so
now that you know where to place the
toast code take a look at the toast
documentation add a toast when the list
item is clicked that contains the
weather information hint you can get the
forecast by getting an item from the
forecast adapter at the position given
by the on item click listener